هذه هي الصور التي نشاهدها مباشره لبعض
المناطق التي شهدت دمارا هائلا في سوريا
الجراء الزلزال الاخير كما نتابع في هذه
اللقطات المباشره والتي تذكر بشكل كبير
بالساعات او السنوات الاولى من الحرب في
سوريا هذه المنطقه تحديدا هي منطقه سرمدا
السوريه وكما نلاحظ اثار الدمار الهائل
جدا الذي لحق بهذه المدينه ابراهيم ما
اكثر المناطق ربما تضررا اكثر المناطق في
سوريا الان التي تحتاج الى تدخل عاجل من
اجل انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه
من تركيا ووصول الى سوريا الحكومه التركيه
كانت تداعلنت الحاله الرابعه من الطوارئ
ان الدوله التركيه بحاجه الى مساعده
خارجيه من دول الجوار والممتحد ان اتحدث
عن دوله قائمه بكيان ومؤسسات فلننتقل الان
الى سوريا والتي لا ترتقي الى مستوى دوله
خاصه في ظل حرب كانت دائره في الماضي ما
بين الشعب والنظام الحاكم ولكن الان على
المستوى الانساني هو اكثر المناطق التي
تحتاجها للمساعدات هي ريف حلب وريف ادلب
لان المنطقه او كانت الاقرب الى مركز
الزلزال الذي كان بتركيا اتحدث عن المدينه
على سيطره النظام اتحدث عن الريف الخاضع
لسيطره المعارضه الذي كان لهم الجرن
الاكبر من اعداد القتل اتحدث عن مدينه
الاتاري بريف حلب الخاضعه المعارضه التي
تحدثت عن 60 قتيل اضافه الى الكثير من
العالقين تحت الانقاذ الذين تحاول الفرق
المختصه اخراجهم القوى العسكريه تحاول شق
الشوارع وفتح الطرق من اجل المساهمه
بعمليه النقل